[Music]
so could you walk people through
the whole body yes and what
the the sort of
flight checklist looks like
yeah well i could have people if we
wanted to go through an experience of
starting to feel what their whole body
yes and nose feels like great yeah let's
do that should we do that it's very
experiential so it'll take about 10
minutes and i'll have people they're
listening i'd recommend they close their
eyes
wonderful
all the time in the world this isn't
morning television okay so the idea is
that your body knows when there's a no
when there's a yes and when there's a
what i'm going to call a subtle no and
we say anything other than a whole body
yes is a no and to your point it's easy
to hear those screaming no's but not so
easy to hear the subtle no for example
someone contacted our organization the
other day and he wanted to
talk
and it wasn't clear to me whether he was
trying to sell us something or whether
he genuinely had clients that he wanted
to connect us with
and even in my
i had suspicions that it wasn't as
clean as he was suggesting
and i asked for clarification and his
clarification still
i couldn't really tell
but
my body didn't know
i felt this flat feeling in my body when
i thought about having the call
and unfortunately my head said well
maybe you're not sure so let's have the
call and indeed it was a sales call and
it was not a good use of my time and i
quickly hung up but i that was a time in
which i skipped over my no because it
was very subtle and my intellect started
to get worried like what if i'm missing
something and you know what if you don't
know
so
i use this all the time and i'm still
learning as i did just last week to
pay attention to the intelligences that
are outside of just my intellect and so
for you all if you want to learn more
about this
what i'd like you to do is close your
eyes
and i'd like you to bring to mind an
experience from the past that was deeply
valuable to you
it was something that was nurturing it
was something you would gratefully
repeat that scene again
it could be
time when you were celebrated it could
be a time when you were in a highly
creative state that made something
valuable
it could be a time when you were in
nature feeling deeply
centered
so i'd like you to go back into that
scene as best you can and
see the images of that scene
and hear the sounds
and as you're in that scene i want you
to start to pay attention to the body
and see if you can notice
just simply
how the body is vibrating right now
when you imagine yourself
in that scene
seeing those images
hearing the sounds
how does your body vibrate
is there a particular direction in which
energy is flowing through the body
now some of you might go diane i'm not
feeling anything here that's fine
just imagine if you were feeling
something
would it be okay that it might feel like
pretend just for now
is there a certain temperature
that you notice in the body
for some people they might feel very
specific sensations
it might feel like shapes inside the
body
and some people might be auditory and
hear tones
or see visuals in their mind's eye
what you're doing here is getting a map
of what does a whole body yes feel like
i'm just strolling around inside of the
body feeling what you're feeling
no right or wrong answers here and
everybody is so unique we all have our
own different ways we feel it
for me my body gets warm
there's a uprising of energy it flows up
for me
there's a push there's a push in the
flow for me
but yours will be what it is
and so then i'd like you to take one
last
like a memory you take a memory shot of
this so you can remember what this feels
like
and then i'd like you to shake it off
and let it go
and then i want you to think of a scene
in the past that you don't want to
repeat
and i don't recommend finding something
traumatizing find something that you
really didn't feel like was a good use
of your time didn't serve you you don't
want to repeat it ever again
or you prefer not to
if you can bring that image to mind
and again
see the visuals of that memory and hear
the sounds
and i want you to notice what happens
now in the body
is there a different
way the body's vibrating
how is the direction of energy flowing
or not flowing in this
version
is there a difference in temperature
any other significant sensations or
shapes you feel in there on the body
and again tones
in the ears or visuals in your mind's
eye may also be included
and you're getting a map for what no
this is a big no
i don't want i don't want this
i don't think this is going to serve me
just mapping the territory in the body
for what does this feel like
and take one last picture of that
and shake that one off
and then we've got one more to do and
this is the subtle note this is similar
to what i was just describing earlier of
taking a meeting
you know it didn't kill me to take the
meeting it didn't hurt i
lasted 10 minutes and i got off the
phone but it wasn't a yes it wasn't an
alive experience for me
so this is called a subtle no so i want
you to think back everybody's got in the
last two to four weeks
something that's happened in which it
was a
it wasn't bad wasn't good
eh
see if you can come back and
see that scene in your mind's eye
and hear those sounds
and you're going to check and see what's
a subtle note feel like for you
how do you experience
that scene what do you notice in the
body
how does it vibrate here
how does energy flow
or not flow
is there a difference in temperature
what parts the body light up sensations
and tones or visuals as well
trying on here and again if you don't
notice much that's okay just imagine if
you did notice what would you notice
and this is your map for what a subtle
no feels like
and you want to remember this feeling so
the next time somebody says hey you want
to go out to lunch or could you meet me
to talk about abc that you if you feel
this likely it's an invitation for you
to try
so you can shake that one off and then
we'll
bring our attention back
to the ongoing conversation
you